- On this episode we talk slime.
(jazzy hip-hop music)
Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is Episode 301
of the Ask Gary Vee show,
and I'm super about this episode
because it's gonna
touch on a lot of things
that I'm passionate about,
families, and entrepreneurship,
and youth culture, trends,
and so without further ado
I have two lovely guests here,
and I'm gonna allow them
to introduce themselves.
- Hi, I'm Maddie.
I'm a slime entrepreneur. (laughs)
- And where do you live Maddie?
- Fairfield, Connecticut.
- And how old are you?
- 13 years old.
- And when did you start your
slime entrepreneurship career?
- I started slime in 2016.
- Got it, and was it first just hobby
and then it became more entrepreneurial?
- It started when my friends
brought slime to school,
so it was more just for fun.
And then it became a business and a hobby.
- Awesome, we'll get into
that in a little bit.
And you sir?
- I'm her father, Howard Greenspan.
- Yes.
- And I actually make slime
too, but not nearly as good.
(laughing)
- So let's set this up for everybody
who's listening and watching.
Obviously we touched on it for a second,
you know, obviously
there's also Slime Bash.
And actually let's start it
that way and I'll go backwards.
For everybody who's
listening, what is Slime Bash?
- So, Slime Bash is the
first ever slime convention,
which actually sparked a trend
of hundreds to even thousands
of slime conventions all over the world.
It's basically where people can
have a booth and they can sell slime,
they can meet their internet friends,
trade slime and have a great time.
- And how long has that been going on?
- Since May, around then
and then we actually...
- May of this year was the first one?
- Yes, May 2018.
- And where was that?
- That was in Stanford, Connecticut.
- Understood.
- And since then you've had how many?
- Two.
- And the last one was in Mohegan Sun?
- Yes.
- And there are a couple coming up?
- Yes, we have Slime
Bash Daytona, Florida,
and then we have Slime Bash Chicago.
- And that's in January?
- Yes, January and March.
- Love it.
- And so you'll be
traveling to these things.
- Yes.
- So are you guys planning and navigating
around school schedule, what's
going on with that stuff?
- Definitely.
(laughing)
- So like, you have school
today, in theory, right?
- Yes. (laughs)
- But having this podcast was
worth a missed school day?
- Definitely.
- I love that.
I mean, listen for
everybody who's watching
as you can imagine I'm
aware of the slime trend,
my daughter got into it.
But more importantly even if she hadn't,
I spend so much time looking
at what's popping in culture
and the internet, and no question
slime has been an amazing phenomenon for
excuse female but plenty of
boys are into it as well,
excuse young but I keep watching
it get younger and older,
it's super interesting
because unlike baseball cards
which was really my version of conventions
and going to booths, and
selling and meeting people,
what's amazing is people
are making the product.
If you are completely lost
on this just Google around,
you'll be blown away by the capabilities
and creativity of the marketplace.
So, let's take a step back.
It's funny I think about,
what grade are you in?
- Eighth grade.
- Awesome, so what in sixth
grade is when you first saw it?
- Yes.
- And so literally as simple as,
and in my fifth grade year
it's funny you bring it up
when you were saying how it went down
it made me think of Garbage Pail Kids.
There's this thing called
Garbage Pail Kids--
(Maddie laughs)
way back in the day, and in fifth grade
it completely took over our school.
Actually I think I have
one on my wall somewhere.
It completely took over out school.
Oh yeah it's right there,
it's that little thing.
That's Geeky Gary.
- Yeah!
- It completely took over our school,
and it literally happened
as simple as one kid came in
the school in fifth grade that had them,
and then like complete hysteria.
Were you early on the
slime trend in sixth grade?
Like your friends came in and had it,
and did you get on quick and
did everybody get into it?
What percentage of the girls in your class
got into it, all that.
Go.
- Well, it started when my friend
brought a ton of slime to school.
She pretty much filled her
entire backpack with slime
and everyone would go to her locker,
take some slime, and we'd just
play with it during class.
- And your teachers let that happen?
- At first they did, now not so much.
- Right.
- But, yeah. (laughs)
- And had you known, had you seen videos,
had you known anything about slime
prior to this girl
bringing slime to school.
- No, I wasn't allowed
to have Instagram then.
- Yep.
- I didn't even know what slime was.
- And so, did you love it immediately?
Or was it just like whatever.
- I mean it was really just whatever.
(Gary laughs)
- I thought it was kind of
weird, I thought it was cool,
I didn't really understand
the creativity behind it
and how you can kind of make it your own.
I thought it was just a basic
white slime and that was it.
- Got it.
And so when did it build, and
how did it build in your mind?
- I think in like December
of 2016 I started to make it,
I got into the trend, and
then I begged my parents
to let me use a slime Instagram.
And then I was like...
- Were you consuming content on YouTube?
- I think I was mostly Instagram then,
now it's sort of moving into YouTube.
But it's mostly Instagram.
- So how did you make your first slime?
You went to your friend's
and you were watching
how-to videos, or how did it go down?
- I was watching how-to videos,
pretty much the YouTube
slime videos were just
how to make basic fluffy
slime, with detergent or borax.
But now it's sort of a creativity thing,
like slime reviews on YouTube,
there's slime challenges,
there's a ton of new stuff.
- Yeah I see it, the trend
is evolving quite a bit.
Where do you think slime is
in its cultural progression?
Do you think slime's gonna
be as popular in three years?
Do you think it's gonna go up and down?
What's your gut, and I know
it's a very difficult question,
it's difficult for anybody,
but just your opinion
on where are we right now?
Are we at the height, do
you see it slowing down,
do you see it picking up
momentum, what's your take?
- I definitely do see people
leaving the community,
the slime community in Instagram.
Just, they're getting tired of it.
But there are people who are
really evolving their business.
There's new trends like every day there's
a new slime trend or a new video trend.
- What's the current, what's the hot thing
right now in slime?
- It's changing your containers. (laughs)
- [Gary] Okay.
- That you put the slime in,
so there's now these
like flat oval containers
rather than--
- Okay, yeah.
- Yeah but they're flat instead
of being larger and taller.
- Yep.
- And those are the new trend now.
- That's what everybody likes?
- Yes. (laughs)
- It's bling.
- The bling in the container.
- It's the packaging really,
is now becoming really popular.
- Yeah for sure.
What's your favorite
part as of this second?
Obviously what's so
amazingly interesting to me
about young entrepreneurs is
when you're in sixth grade,
like when you're in eighth grade
your life is evolving very quickly.
Not only your business, and so things
that you think are cool and things
that you're interested
in are moving very fast.
And so I'm always fascinated by that.
For you at this point,
is it about the making,
is it about the creativity,
is it about building a
business with your dad?
What is the best part currently
of the whole slime thing?
- Well, I like the
creativity aspect definitely.
I like how slime is a product
and you can make it however you'd like.
It's sort of the design aspect toO,
like I can design packaging,
I can design the slime,
the label, everything.
- Yep, so you still love making it.
- Yes.
- That's awesome.
- Thank you. (laughs)
- Now jump in here and
speak to the parents
of young entrepreneurs and trends,
and more importantly
before we even get into
the macro of it all, I'd love to know
a little bit about your backstory.
Like you professionally,
when did this first hit you,
give me the whole narrative.
What do you do, when did
it first hit your radar,
and how did things evolve
with you guys together?
- Okay, well I like to
think I'm an active dad.
My business background is I
went to school for business,
was in marketing and product development,
and I have very similar
entrepreneurial aspects.
I used to sell baseball cards myself,
back when I was a little teen.
- Where'd you grow up?
- In Connecticut.
- Love it.
- I used to do the shows.
- Are you a New York-based sports fan
or a Boston-based sports fan?
- New York based.
(laughing)
- Connecticut's a very weird place.
- New York definitely.
- Yeah, I was definitely leading down
do you like the patriots
because if you do your daughter
and you have to get out
of my office right now.
(laughing)
That's exactly where that was going.
Go ahead.
- Right now my company
makes a lot of products.
I remember the day when Madison,
or Maddie, came over, sorry.
(laughing)
When Maddie came and said--
- And is Rae your middle name?
- Yes.
- Understood.
- So Maddie came to me and
said let's go look for glue,
and everybody was sold out, and I'm like
I don't know what to tell you Maddie.
And she says well can we just
make it, or can I make it.
And that was how it all
started way back when.
- Can I make glue?
- Mm-hmm.
- That's a great question.
- And we're like I don't know
I've never made glue before
but I guess we can figure it out.
- And it's 2019, you know.
How to make glue, enter.
- Yeah, so from a parent perspective
it's wonderful working with her,
doing anything with your kid because--
- So what happened next, I
apologize John to bring you back.
- [Howard] It's all right.
- So she comes, I don't know what happens
you found some glue somewhere
or you started trying to make glue.
- Well we sourced it in China. (laughs)
(laughing)
- You went hardcore.
- Yeah.
- You're like let's cut everybody out.
- Well they don't really
have a glue industry
in the United States, so
we have to go overseas.
But you're talking about real volume.
- Yeah, well--
- The normal person that's listening
they went and bought a couple Elmer's
and they made some slime.
You know if you're going direct to China
you're talking about scale.
- Yeah, well--
- How quickly did it go
from like, Maddie Rae,
from you being like I want
to make slime to like,
did you want to sell slime right away?
- I did, I didn't really know
what that really meant, so.
- But you did right?
I love that, by the way.
That excited me.
That is my childhood, everything
was about selling something
so it's just an entrepreneurial trait.
- Like so many, I don't want
to mention a lot of young kids,
but I know 15 girls
that like making slime,
zero of them want to sell
it, I desperately tried.
But you wanted to sell right away?
- I did, I didn't really
know how to make a website
or anything so it did take me a while.
- And were you thinking that way?
Were you thinking make,
sell on the internet,
Instagram account not I'm
gonna sling this in school?
- Yes.
- Did you think you'd
get some sales in school?
Or you didn't want to mix your business
with your social life?
- I mean, I had friends
who were already selling it
at school so I didn't really think
that that was a good idea to also sell.
- You didn't want to get the competitive
business environment
to destroy friendships.
- Yes. (laughing)
- No, that's super smart I get it.
I love that. (laughs)
Okay, so what happened.
When she came to you, or
when it hit your radar,
was it very much in the beginning
or did she have interests,
you saw her making some?
- I didn't really know
it was gonna be anything
to be honest.
But I thought it was a good
education for her, for me.
- [Gary] Yeah you're pumped about that.
- We started having board
meetings every week. (laughs)
- So real quick 'cause we're
bouncing here a little bit,
she comes to you and
immediately it's like,
"Dad I want to start a slime business."
And you're like let's do this together?
- Well she said that, I don't make slime,
as I said I make a little bit now...
- I've heard.
(Maddie laughs)
- But it's not very great.
But she wanted to talk about glue,
and consumer products are what I do,
what my company does, and I thought
it was a great opportunity
to do that aspect together.
- Got it.
So the thought was,
just because I'm putting
the pieces together,
maybe start a glue brand
and sell the glue because
glue was starting to dry up?
- Well, the idea was that, you're a parent
at the beginning of the glue
phase, and the slime phase,
and there was Elmer's and other products.
But I remember when we first started
we bought rubber cement, we
didn't know what glue worked.
So if you have slime glue
it takes the guesswork
out of the parents, and
that's where it all started.
And now she's developed
so many different products
in the glue field, and the slime field,
and the accessory field.
- And is that selling
on Shopify and Amazon?
Or what's happening with your products.
- Well sell it on
SlimeMaking.com and Amazon.
- Got it.
And is that Shopify or what
are you using on the backend?
I'm just curious.
- On the backend it's Shopify and Amazon.
- Cool.
- Amazon uses their own interface.
- And who's doing the fulfillment
when they buy it directly
from your website?
- Most things are gonna
siphon thorough Amazon.
- Got it, understood.
And how's that experience been?
- Good.
- You've learned a lot?
- Yes, definitely.
I learned how to run a business
which is a lot. (laughs)
- Do you think that's something
you're gonna want to do eventually?
Or are you not sure yet?
- I don't really think I want to
own a business with
products but I definitely
would want to run my own business.
- Love it.
So what happens next, so this starts.
At first dad you don't
think it's gonna be that big
and how quickly did you say, "Holy crap
there's like a whole universe of this"
and this is a clearly
fast-moving emerging trend
in society and has some legs.
- Well I remember we sat down,
all of us including Maddie
and we're just brainstorming
about fun crazy ideas
to get people to know about our brand.
And one of the things came up,
why don't we break a world record.
And Maddie's like let's
break a world record.
So the team was like we can't do it.
And the slogan became
"We can do it." (laughs)
- Yeah.
- So what happened there Maddie?
- Well, we did break the world record.
- What was the record you went after?
- The world's largest slime.
- Love it.
- And what was it at the time?
- There wasn't actually a record
so we wanted to start it.
- Right, so you could've made anything.
- No they tell you.
- They tell you a minimum?
- If there's nothing out there
they're gonna make something crazy.
- Interesting.
We're talking Guinness?
- Guinness themselves.
- That's amazing, so you held at one point
or still hold a Guinness
Book of World Records record?
- Yes.
- You still hold it or somebody got crazy
and decided like--
- Oh no, no one's beat it yet. (laughs)
- Really?
- [Maddie] Yeah.
- So wait real quick,
you hold the world record
for the largest slime.
- Yes.
- Which is?
- 13,820 pounds.
(laughing)
- Where'd you put it?
- Well, we put it in a giant
pool, it was really crazy.
We had a hundred people just in the pool
mixing the slime with
their hands and feet.
- [Gary] Is that video online?
- [Maddie] Yes.
- [Gary] Is it remarkable?
Like I gotta check it out,
how many views is it at?
- [Howard] Oh gosh.
- I mean we had a lot
of influencers there,
so every person made a different video.
- Yep.
- But one of our influencers
had 20 million views now.
- (laughs) I love it.
(Howard laughs)
- There's a lot of different ones.
- Is it Keep Calm and Blush On?
Yeah that one.
- That's not the one.
- This is it.
- Yeah that's not our video, but...
- Amazing.
- So what's the biggest thing dad
that you learned from this experience.
For obviously knowing my
audience of this podcast
there's a lot of you
(laughs) listening right now,
what are some of your
advice, what's your tips.
Has there been fights,
has there been arguments?
How's it gone, what has made it work?
Keep him honest Maddie.
(Maddie laughs)
- I think for the most part
the kids today are incredible,
they can do anything.
- 100%.
- And I mean it's amazing.
Their learning capacity is
so much faster than adults.
- They just have so much more
information at their fingertips.
- Absolutely.
- Like we could've done this too, bro.
But the problem is we had
Beckett Baseball Card Guide
and that was the only information we had.
- Yeah, I learned Final Cut Pro in a month
and she learns it in an hour.
- 100%
- So I think it's a matter.
- I mean you and I could've been friends,
I was in Jersey you were in Connecticut,
we could've been baseball card friends
but we didn't have the technology
stack called the internet
to allow us to have that.
- Right, people's best friends
are all over the country now.
- Real quick stay on this for a second.
I get a lot of pushback
on modern-day parenting
and technology, and everybody talks about,
our kids are so introverted,
they don't have social skills,
and I keep arguing they
have so many friends
in different places and are more social,
they're just communicating
with a different device
than me and you meeting at the
mall at 4:30 at the arcade.
Your thoughts about that?
- My parents would say gosh
we're watching too much TV.
Everything's always something
with a different age,
and our jobs as parents
is to understand it--
- Do you know which Mike
Tyson's Punchout I played?
- Love it.
- Unlimited.
- So I get it, okay so--
- So our job is to
understand it and to adapt,
and to encourage whatever they do.
- Yes culture versus no culture.
- Yes.
- I love it.
- How is the event's business?
Like is this super exciting?
It seems like it's getting big.
- Yes it is.
- Is it taxing?
It's a lot of work to throw events
at this scale that you guys are,
how many people went
to the Mohegan Sun one?
- 7,000.
- I mean you're talking
about a real business.
- [Maddie] Yeah.
- How are you guys thinking
about this right now?
- It's an enormous undertaking.
But as people I think, I'll
quote my little 6 year old,
and I'm sure Maddie feels the same way,
the greatest weekend of our life,
(laughs) better than Disney World.
- Yeah, we asked her if she'd rather go
to Disney or Slime Bash and
she said Slime Bash. (laughs)
- Awesome, is she making slime?
- Yes.
- I love it.
Is she good?
She's 6 right?
- Yeah.
- Are you a slime snob?
Your reaction here is like--
(laughing)
Do you have a high barrier to
entry to being good at slime?
- Yeah.
- Let's give some love to the community
because I'm also aware a
lot of the famous influences
drove to Connecticut, I'm in
the scene, I have a good sense.
Who do you think is doing
a good job out there
at making slime and promoting
themselves on YouTube,
and who did you see get a lot of love
at your Slime Bash at their booths.
Who impresses you in the community?
- Like the Instagrammers?
- Sure, anybody.
Who do you think is doing
a good job out there?
- I think Parakeet Slimes,
she's a great influence on people.
She had a huge line.
- [Gary] Yep, I saw.
- People really love her account,
they love her personality.
- Who else?
- Karina Garcia, she has
8 million subscribers.
It was really great to
see her meeting everyone.
- Yep, she's pretty OG right,
like she's like a big name.
- Yeah, she was definitely one
of the first slime accounts,
she's also DIY too.
And then also I think
everyone in Slimers Alley
which is sort of like the rising slimers.
They all gained so many
followers from Slime Bash,
it was really great to see that too.
- What are your friends
thinking about this?
Now in eighth grade versus sixth grade.
It's very, just knowing kids,
it's really interesting.
You're starting to go to another
chapter of your adolescence
and do they think slime's not as cool
but it's cool that you're in business?
What's the take right now?
Are you in a school where
eighth grade is the oldest grade
and there's younger kids in the school?
- [Maddie] Yes.
- So do some of the fourth
graders think you're famous
and want to take selfies?
- What's happening in
the trenches at school?
- Well, the little kids
it's really funny they
always like come up to me--
- Are you K through eight, or
are you fifth through eight?
- We're Pre-K, three, four,
and then K through eight.
- Right, so that's interesting.
Go ahead.
So what's happening with the youngsters?
- They're not really on Instagram,
but one time I did receive
a really sweet note
from a little fourth grader who asked
if I wanted to hang out with her one day
and make slime, which was really nice.
But a lot of my friends at
school they don't like slime,
some of them really hate it but they think
Slime Bash is really cool,
they all went to the world record.
So, yeah.
- That's how it's working.
You know, one of the things
that's really interesting to me
about this trend and you just
brought it up with Garcia,
I'd like to get your thoughts on this.
The do it yourself movement,
do you think that slime
is going to graduate a lot of young girls
into being creators in other areas?
- Definitely, I think a
lot of people are actually
moving to vlogging, like Parakeet Slimes
who I was talking about before,
she's now doing school vlogs all the time.
- What about soap?
Have you seen that?
- Oh yeah, soap cutting. (laughs)
- Yeah what are you seeing with that?
- ASMR in general,
(laughs) like eating ASMR.
- Of course.
- Yeah there's eating
ASMR, there's slime ASMR,
like ASMR is kind of a large category now
so people are definitely
moving towards that too.
- What else should
parents know about this,
think about it, entrepreneurship, slime,
what's some of your hot takes?
- Well, I think the key is that
there's always gonna be something,
and parents you don't always
have to approve of anything.
Most parents are beginning
it in their households
because of the mess, and kids make messes.
I think it's better to
teach them responsibleness
of making slime, make them
clean up after themselves.
- Yeah its a mess.
- But if you make them clean up
versus just saying gee
it's going to be a mess
I think you have to temper what you do
to what you encourage your kids
versus what you don't encourage your kids.
Because there's a domino effect positively
and negative to whatever
you do to your kids.
- I couldn't agree more.
Talk to me about, you
talked about marketing
and being an entrepreneur,
what have you learned
about the current state of marketing
through this adventure
of slime, if anything.
- Well, I've learned a lot
about the influencer world
which is not my bandwagon,
that's the new generation,
the power of the
generation, this generation
could move the NFL to shut
down just with a couple tweets.
So it's really fascinating
that just in a niche
of something to the new, let me go back,
the new superstars are Parakeet
Slimes versus Taylor Swift.
I think if they were both next
to each other at Slime Bash,
I think Parakeet would have a larger line.
- [Gary] I understand.
- And that's fascinating, and I think
we all have to understand it because this
is the generation that's
gonna rule the next world.
- 100%.
Any questions you have for me?
- Are you sure you want
to buy the Jets? (laughs)
- 100,000%.
(laughing)
More than anything professionally.
- Can you make them good?
- 100,000%, because everything
in life stems from the top.
- Then I'm not gonna buy it,
I'm gonna go for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
I'll let you have that.
(laughing)
- Is Tampa on your radar, or just random?
Maddie what should, for
everybody who's listening,
what should they know
about the slime movement,
the DIY movement, just the whole scene.
- I think that a lot of people
view slime as like a fad,
or in a trend but really
there's a large community
of people who are making
it and it's now a job
for a ton of people, so yeah. (laughs)
- What's been the most surprising thing
in the last month, in the trends, sales
anything stand out to
you if I'm just trying to
siphon some IP from you
on things that are
happening in the trenches.
What's kind of interesting?
So I like the flat
container thing, what else?
- Well now slime acrobatics
are actually becoming a thing.
So there's something
called slime flipping,
where you take the slime
and you flip it and--
- Try to make a big like bubble?
- It's not really making
a bubble it's like
doing tricks with the slime.
- Yep, so that's the acrobatics?
- So, yeah, it's like the way you flip it.
- Are you doing that?
- I'm really bad at it, so not really,
but there are people who
have made really cool videos
of them flipping slime,
so it's really cool
to see the new tricks
that people come up with.
- I love it, so, please.
- I had a question though,
I'd love to know your thoughts
just in general about the conventions,
because one of the things
that we find fascinating,
or I do, is that this is
one of the first times
that you have this internet
world of influencers
and millions of kids around the world
that are actually leaving the internet
and coming to meet their communities,
and inspiring kids to come out.
- This is happening and has been happening
for the last half decade, the trend of
as we live in a digital world
it enhances real-life experiences.
Whether it's as simple as
people going and taking a hike
because they want the
photo for their Instagram.
Or look, when Vine was popping a lot of
the teeny bopper boys, Nash
Greer and Cameron Dallas,
and these characters they went on tour
and had 30,000, 40,000, VidCon
gets hundreds of thousands.
This has been going on and
will continue to go on.
I do think that there will be,
whether it's fads or
long trends like look,
when your dad and I were growing up
baseball cards were massive,
then for 20 years they weren't,
now there's a bubbling up again.
Like to your point I
don't think slime will be
as white hot as it is
right now in perpetuity.
It will peak and valley,
but do I think it got
so hot and so at scale that
it will now have cycles, I do.
I feel like if I was predicting
I'd be like okay it has another
three years of goodness.
Then it starts really
kind of calming down.
It's still happening, there's
still plenty of people making,
but it's not in the zeitgeist,
attendance to something
like Slime Bash peaks at 50,000,
goes down to 8,000 and
6,000 seven years later
if you guys ran it forever,
and then it reboots.
That's what always happens, that's what
happens with G.I. Joe, that's
what happens with wrestling.
That's what happens with '90s clothes,
that's what happening now
with Fila and Tommy Hilfiger.
So what I think Slime has accomplished
that a lot of other fads don't,
where they only have a six month window,
and nine month white heat window,
pencil fighting, do you
remember pencil fighting?
Did you have that?
- [Howard] Whenever they flick 'em?
- Yeah.
- [Howard] Yeah.
- So that was huge for us
in sixth and seventh grade.
That wasn't big enough, and
didn't sustain long enough
that it's coming back every
five, seven, ten years,
I do think slime has that.
As far as the events, marketing business,
I couldn't be more bullish.
I think what you put in the container
of these convention centers
and casinos will change.
Some things have 100-year runs,
some things have 3-year
blips then they come back.
But yeah I think of it like Aerosmith
and Rolling Stones and Run DMC.
Once you can establish
something it ebbs and flows,
but it's always kind of around.
- [Howard] Absolutely.
- Look it's an intense
business, it's taxing right.
You could make a lot of,
you could build a warehouse
in your back yard if you had the space
to make a ton of slime, and sell it
through Amazon, but schlepping to Daytona
and making sure everything's right.
But the experience is like look,
I'm in agreement with your 6 year old,
the thought that your family's
gonna have this adventure
and remember this time
together too is just
disproportionately valuable in my opinion.
- Absolutely, and we do it
all together so it's great.
- Oh I have a question for you Maddie,
one thing that I'm very passionate about
is what I call the super
premium category of any product.
I'm always most interested in how much
can you actually charge
for something, right.
So for example a big dream of mine
has always been to start
a $20 pack of bubble gum.
Like that's expensive for bubble gum.
But $20 is achievable for a lot of people,
so I've always thought it's
an interesting category.
What's the most expensive
slime you've seen?
What was the single most
expensive slime sold at Slime Bash
or you've seen recently on
Instagram from an influencer?
Has anybody made something
really expensive yet?
- Well there's 32 ounces are becoming
a really big trend now.
- And what were the ounces before that?
- Most people sell in
2, 4, 6, and 8 ounces.
So 32 ounces--
- 32 is like bulk.
- Yeah it's really big.
I've seen people charge
as much as $50 for them.
- What's the most expensive 8 ounce slime
you can think of that you've seen
in the last year and a half?
- Probably $17.
- [Gary] And what was that?
- I believe it was a butter
slime because it contained
a lot of daiso clay
which is very expensive.
- Understood.
- And scent, so fragrance oil.
- Yeah the scent thing seems
to be popping too, right?
- Yeah, it's very expensive though.
So a 32 ounce would use a bottle of scent.
- Understood.
- But you bring an interesting point,
I wonder if there's like, you
could put real gold flakes
in something or limited
edition of only seven made.
- Yeah I mean when you get big enough,
when you're Parakeet,
when you're Brian Anthony,
like these kind of
characters you could just say
I'm only making 25 of these,
here's what I'm doing with it.
I do think, look again I'm using it 'cause
it's our context point,
Upper Deck came along.
- Yep, where they had limited runs.
- Yep, just it was expensive.
We were paying 50 cents a pack for cards
and then it was $2, it was like
(imitating explosion
sound) that was insanity.
I do think there's an absolute category
for one of the influencers
to take that leap
and create a super premium category.
And I do think that there
are plenty of people,
like Maddie this may
sound interesting to you
given that you're in the trenches,
I do believe that there
is a $50 8 ounce slime
to be sold in the slime
community, I really do.
- There's the advent calendar.
- Yeah some people, I've
seen someone charge $169
for an advent calendar.
- What's an advent calendar?
- You've confused Gary.
(inaudible)
- Oh that's the open thing?
That's what it's called?
- 25 days of slime.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- It's not really like a door,
you don't open the doors.
It's just a giant box full of 25 slimes.
- Understood.
25 slimes for a buck what?
- $169.
- What for 25 slimes?
- Yeah so that's pretty good.
- I mean that's a good deal,
but I understand the bulk of it.
No really I'm really curious if somebody's
gonna come out and make
$49 slime in an 8 ounce
and say that the tears
of a seal are a part,
really like that's the stuff.
Or one could, you know listen
what's amazing about the
internet is there some,
can you add the water from
a creek in your backyard
and because you've been
vlogging and everybody
gives a crap about that
creek, like there's so much
creativity that is still yet to be solved.
- For the conventions
there's the mega bash ticket
which gives people a premium,
and they always sell out immediately.
The first Slime Bash
sold out in ten minutes.
- Yeah how did that go down?
Let's talk about that, event marketing.
You sold 7,000 tickets in how fast?
- Well the first convention sold out
their premium tickets
in about eight minutes.
- And how do you promote it?
Just your, what?
- My Instagram, but we had VIP slimers
which are like the famous influencers,
so they really promoted it.
People wanted to meet them so they came
and bought the tickets.
- And so did you have
to learn to negotiate
with these people for
their appearance fees,
or did they just want the
exposure, what went down?
- This is the first time
that it was ever done,
and they want to meet their fans,
they want to meet their communities,
and they're gonna sell a lot of slime.
- That's right.
- And it was sort of like a special thing
to be a part of the first
ever slime convention.
So it was really cool to--
- So it was a win-win for everybody,
they came, got to meet everybody,
they sold enough slime that
it was well worth their while.
- Before we sat down
you guys were gracious
and said we have four
tickets to give away,
how would you like to
functionally do that?
Do you want people to
follow you on Instagram
and then leave a comment
that they want the tickets?
Any functionality of how we
want to give away these tickets?
Are you trying to build up
any of your other channels?
Have you started building
up your Twitter yet?
- I don't think you have
a Twitter account yet.
- So it's Instagram only for you?
- Yeah.
- So maybe they can go on your,
if they post on your Instagram.
- Why don't we do this,
everybody who's listening
if you want tickets to Florida or Chicago,
is it SlimeBash.com for details?
- Yes.
- Cool, so just go to SlimeBash.com
to see the dates for the details,
and whether it's Chicago or Florida
why don't you go to, and
what's your Instagram handle?
- Slimebymaddierae.
- Yes.
- Okay, R-A-E?
- Cool, go to her Instagram account
and leave in the comment
section #garysentme.
#Garysentme and then I'll let them
figure out who they're
gonna pick and how and what.
Yeah.
- I just have a quick question.
- Sure.
- Because I think it will
help everybody who's listening
Maddie talks about having
increased following
- Who is this voice from
the outside, tell everybody.
- This is Denise Hawkins,
I'm a director with PR.
- Yep.
- You talk a lot about
documenting your journey.
- Yes.
- Maddie is a shy girl and
is not really comfortable
with documenting her
journey, however we all know
that that the human interest piece
is very interesting to a lot of people,
that's what we're wanting from you.
- Yes.
- So can you talk to both Howie and Maddie
about (inaudible) please.
- Well, not to upset
you for what you set up.
(laughing)
I believe in it tremendously,
but I do not believe
that people should do things
that they're uncomfortable with
for the sake of what's the right tactic.
Listen, it's a big jump.
I only understand how to
deploy empathy, right.
It's my core.
When you're an eighth grade girl
and you're not interested
in documenting your life,
even though it's disproportionately
helpful for the ambition,
I have to be empathetic.
Thoughts, you were about to say something.
- Yes, not necessarily her life,
I should've explained that.
Probably your business
life, when you are with us
and we are having our meetings,
we're talking about
different design aspects
you're looking at, different charts.
- But you'll appreciate
this, but even that.
As much as it would be remarkably good
for the business for you sitting down
and having those brainstorming meetings,
you know how interesting it would be
to see the video of how
you came up with the idea
for the largest slime in the world
after it has hundreds of million of views?
That's what I'm doing, I'm documenting,
I've got content that I'm
gonna show in 19 years
that proved that this wasn't a mistake,
that this was strategy.
And so, yes it's (indistinct)
and the other thing
Maddie I will tell you,
you will unbelievably,
god willing love to watch
these videos of you going
through this process
with your daughter one
day, I promise you that.
I'm devastated that I don't have videos,
or I don't have a picture.
I do not have a single picture
of me at a baseball card show.
- I don't either.
- And that destroys my soul.
So I will say one thing to think about
which is hard to think about at this age
is how awesome it's gonna
be to have these videos
to look back on, and one
thing you guys could consider
is documenting them, and
if you're not comfortable
not releasing them and
maybe releasing them later.
They're good to have in a lot of ways,
so that's one thing you may want to think.
But I do think if you don't want it out,
listen we have to be empathetic.
If you don't want them out there
because you don't want your friends
critiquing it in eighth grade,
fuckin' eighth grade you care
about your friends opinions
a lot no matter how entrepreneurial
or how awesome your parents are.
That's life, and I think
it's dangerous to push people
into things that don't
come natural to them.
But no question you're 100% right,
documenting, the content is
just valuable as heck, Maddie.
You know.
- Yeah, I definitely agree.
I think I do like to
document my business life
more than my personal.
- Makes sense.
How do you think about the
other social media platforms?
Actually let me step out for
a second from all of this.
What's going on in school?
In eighth grade, in your
class, what are the core
social networks that
people are using right now?
- Instagram and Snapchat.
- That's it?
- I mean, my friends watch YouTube
but they don't have YouTube channels.
- Understood.
Consuming YouTube not creating,
consuming and creating on
Instagram and Snapchat.
- Yes.
- And if I said 100% of the activities
between Instagram and Snapchat
is it 80-20 Instagram?
50-50?
- I'd say most people have
Instagram and Snapchat.
I don't have Snapchat, but I know
that most of my class has Instagram.
So 80-20 probably.
- Twitter, no?
- No.
- Nobody.
I don't think anyone in my
class has Twitter. (laughs)
- And Facebook's like for your dad.
- Yeah.
- Super for your dad.
- Like you would never consider
going to that boring place.
- No.
- Right.
(laughing)
- What percentage of your class
are creating videos for YouTube?
- There's only one person in my class
who's really creating.
Actually, no two.
- Okay, what about podcasts.
Is anybody listening to podcasts?
- I'm not sure.
- Understood.
- I don't know.
- Anything else interesting,
anything else popping?
- TicToc, but it's mostly for my class
it's mostly like a meme to them.
- Yep.
- And it's mostly like a joke.
It's not really, no one
really makes TikToks for fun.
- And does everybody realize
it's like old Musical.ly?
- Yeah.
- Like is there an understanding?
And were people on musically
like three years ago?
- Yes, my class loved Musical.ly. (laughs)
- And for that reason is there a little
love for TikTok as like
a reminiscing thing?
- I think so, yeah I think so.
- Guys I have to get an account there.
(laughs)
- I used to be on
Musical.ly, it wasn't pretty.
- I had a couple funny Musical.lys myself.
(laughing)
- [Howard] Do we have to go find those?
- Maddie, Howie I really appreciate
you guys being on the show.
It's really a show I've been waiting to do
mainly because it's just
so much of what I believe
and care about, and it's super impressive.
And I'm so excited for
your success Maddie,
and the events business is
just super interesting to me.
It's just so much good,
and I'm always here to help if I can.
- Thank you.
- Any last words?
- Thank you for having
me on the show. (laughs)
- You're welcome.
- Yeah what you're doing is great,
and yeah we'd love any
kind of feedback honestly.
- Thanks.
- Never stop learning.
- Cool.
Thanks for listening everybody.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop drum beat)